so we're told to factor the polynomial
below by its greatest common monomial
factor so what does that mean so we have
these two terms and I want to figure out
their greatest common monomial factor
and then I want to express this with
that greatest common monomial factor
factored out so I can we tackle it well
one way to start is I can look at just
the constant terms I can look it or not
the constants the coefficients I should
say so I have the 8 and the 12 and I
could say well what is just the greatest
common factor of 8 and 12 the GCF of 8
and 12 and there are a lot of common
factors of 8 and 12 they're both
divisible by 1 they're both divisible by
2 they're both divisible by 4 but the
greatest of their common factors is
going to be 4 so that is equal to 4 so I
could let me just leave that there and
then we could think about what is let me
actually write it right over here I'll
put a 4 here and now we can move on to
the powers of X we have an x squared and
we have an X and we can say what is the
largest power of X that is divisible
into both x squared and X well that's
just going to be X x squared is clearly
divisible by X and X is clearly
divisible by X but X isn't going to be
isn't is it going to have a larger power
of X as a factor so this is the greatest
you could do this is the greatest common
monomial factor of x squared and X now
we do the same thing for the Y's so we
have a Y and a y squared if we think in
the same terms the largest part of Y
that's divisible into both of these is
going to be just Y to the first power or
Y and so for X Y is the greatest common
monomial factor and to see that we can
express each of these terms as a product
of 4 X Y and something else so this
first term right over here so let me
pick a color so this term right over
here we could write as 4 X Y that's that
one's actually that color is hard to see
let me pick a darker color we could
write this right over here as 4 XY times
what and I encourage you to pause the
video and think about
let's see four times what is equal is
going to get us to eight
well four times two is going to get us
to eight x times what is going to get us
to x squared well x times X is going to
get us to x squared and then Y times
what is going to get us to Y what's just
going to be y so for X Y times two x is
actually going to give us this first
term so actually let me just rewrite a
little bit differently so it's for X Y
times 2x is this first term and you can
you can verify that four times two is
going to be equal to eight x times X is
equal to x squared and then you just
have the Y now let's do the same thing
with the second term and I just want to
do this to show you that they vote that
this is their largest common monomial
factor so the second term and I'll do
this in a slightly different color do it
in blue I want to write this as the
product of four X Y and another and
another monomial so four times what is
12
well four times three is 12 x times what
is X well it just going to be one so
we'd have to write up times one here and
then Y times what is Y squared it's
going to be Y times y is y squared and
you can verify if you multiply these two
you're going to get 12x y squared four
times three is twelve you get your X and
then Y times y is y squared so so far
I've written this exact same expression
but I've taken each of those terms and I
factored them into the greatest common
monomial their greatest common monomial
factor and then whatever is left over
and now I can factor the 4 X Y out I can
actually factor it out so this is going
to be equal to if i factor the 4 x wise
out you can kind of say i undistribute
the four XY if i factor it out this is
going to be equal to four XY x times two
x two x plus when i factor 4 it's live
from here I get the three Y leftover
plus three
why and we are done and you can verify
it if you if you were to go the other
way if you were to distribute this for X
Y and multiply it times 2x you get 8x
squared Y and then when you distribute
the 4 X Y onto the 3y you get the 12 X Y
squared and so we're done this right
over here is our answer that the answer
is going to be 4 X Y which is the
greatest common monomial factor x 2x
plus 3y